good morning welcome to this joint
overview of scrutiny committee meeting
by first of all remind you of some of
the domestic arrangements toilets are
situated outside the meeting room
opposite of stairs cold water is also
available in the breakout area outside
the meeting room if the fire alarm
should sound please leave the meeting
room by following the fire exit signs
and meet on the Ipswich Town Football
Club training page please do not use the
atrium stairs to exit the building do
not re-enter the building until you are
told it is safe to do so please switch
off all mobile phones or turn them to
silent I'd like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the Internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing the whole
of the meeting will be filmed except
where there are confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you would we will be deemed
by the council to of consented to being
filmed by entering this room you are
also consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and/or training purposes the
council members of the public and the
press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
finally can members and officers please
ensure that you press the microphone for
speaking and turn it off when you are
finished thank you
so until item 1 apologies and
substitutes none receive chest thank you
do we have any declarations of interests
ok item 3 these are the minutes of the
meeting held on the 8th of January 2020
we had two meetings on that day this
meeting is the meeting about the
corporate plan outputs agenda item 3 so
do we have any requests for amendments
should we go page 5 6 7 8 9
thank you castor scarf take a check H
950 1.19 it says I cleared the
environment outputs in relation to car
parking in stone market and asked for
further details that's not quite what I
asked I know that within the corporate
outputs there was a reverb car parking
within beta and my query related to
weather review for stone market could be
considered looking in particular exits
and entrances and in particular Milton
Road car park so if that helps to
clarify the minutes
thank you we can do that thank you with
that with that amendment is everyone
happy that I should sign these minutes
as a true record yes proposed over the
Second Council Rosberg councilman Waller
and all were in favor I believe
thank you very much right we now go on
to another of the meetings held on that
same day this is the meeting to consider
the Western Suffolk Community Safety
Partnership so are there any requests
for amendments on page 13
that we have we have one or two
amendments here listed which will go
through a TN 14 15 16 17 18 19 and 20
the opera's has got some amendments that
have been sent in by email yes yeah
thank you so I'm just going to read
through the amendments so 5.19 changed
to relatively 5.23 involved in 17 to 20
cases five-point 28 counselor heading
ham had experienced abroad 5.2 31 but
with the support of the head teachers
there was a growing and we had to remove
had helped 5.30 to add as indicated by
recent press reports 5.37 to add once
mental health issues or abused had been
established appear to be a problem
finding a solution to this was important
and 5.38 to add in between i think he
and the council that makes sense to
everyone and i can say that the
published minutes and the sign when it's
all include these amendments
so with those amendments can have a
proposal a seconder thank you
Castaneda councillor Hannigan and is
everyone in favor of approving the
minutes yes thank you very much so we're
on to item 5 any notification of
petitions
thank you questions by the public none
received questions by councillors none
received chair thank you so we go to the
the main item on the agenda which is to
consider the planning enforcement the
report jos 1925
we have we have three offices were for
is now Tom Barker Phyllis bill Sammon
Bailey and Julie have odd are here I
think Phil's going to give a
presentation first can I say that I
found this an excellent report and it
gives us a very clear introduction into
half planning enforcement has been
managed in the recent past changes that
have recently been implemented and a
recommendation for next steps so if you
are content will listen to Phil's
presentation and then we'll take
questions for the offices before we go
into debate they keep though
Thank You chairman and good morning
members so there are two recommendations
before you but perhaps before we touch
on those it's appropriate just to
headline some of the the important
context to this report I think the most
useful thing I can start with is draw
your attention to the advice of the MPP
F in paragraph nine point seven which
fairly simply and succinctly describes
in paragraph 58 of the MPP F how we are
expected to apply enforcement as an
activity it reminds our authorities that
enforcement action is discretionary so
it is a choice and that it requires
proportionate responses it is something
where well must measure and take a
balanced approach to the enforcement
investigation that you undertake and it
describes the value and importance of
having a local employer enforcement plan
which the government expects to set out
how counselors propose to monitor
investigators and take action where
appropriate
so in headline terms the expectation is
that all councils will have a local
enforcement plan which describes how we
do enforcement and what we do and sets
out some standards and it's fair to say
that there are all shades of of how
enforcement plans are undertaken ours is
included in a link or with the papers as
Appendix A just so to put some context
to this you know
local enforcement plan Parador 6.4 we
talked about three priorities of
enforcement investigation high priority
cases medium priority and low priority
cases and the significance of that is
then played out in paragraph seven point
three which describes the timetable that
we set for ourselves in visiting sites
in each of those categories and
effectively the the the cases which are
of greatest potential concern and most
urgent a high priority cases which we
say we will visit within three working
days and then we talk to the the medium
and low priority cases as being matters
we will investigate on the site within
five and fifteen days respectively now
that's that's a fairly standard approach
to most local enforcement policies if it
if you can call on that
to categorize harm and to approach it in
in a way which describes the priority
that you give to attending on site we
also in paragraph seven point two a
confirm that will acknowledge receipt of
any request to investigate something
within three working days so those are
those are effective the starting the
starting points for any investigation
and from our perspective the question
where an investigation then goes becomes
a matter of what is proportionate what
is balanced and what information do you
need in order to successfully follow an
investigation to its conclusion it is
not a it is not unlawful to break
planning law I was something that was
considered by the government back in the
1990's and shied away from and I think
it's fair to say it remains a source of
some tension with those who are
receiving what they perceive as harm an
arising from a breach of planning
control the breach playing control.if
investigated to its logical conclusion
will either conclude that one might
grant planning permission
anyway and an investigation is not
successfully pursued simply for the sake
of inviting a planning application where
that would achieve nothing
well there are other alternative
mechanisms available to the authority to
remedy matters which cause harm they
include an enforcement notice they
include breach of condition notice and
they include the potential to ultimately
go to court and seek an injunction where
matters are not satisfactorily resolved
and if you look in your papers one of
the case studies concerning a change of
use shows the timeline of critical
actions through from investigations
through to an injunction and as you'll
see I think that that that case involves
some five years worth of time taken to
go through that process it's fair to say
that enforcement in that is not a a
swift process but it has to be done in a
balanced and measured way because it
does affect people's rights to use land
and it is therefore an important thing
there are other approaches to describing
how you investigate harm and we're aware
that various other councils have done
this in other ways both describing harm
complexity and urgency and the
recommendation that you have before you
is effectively to establish a member of
a task and finish group to look at the
joint local planning enforcement plan
and to review it having regard to best
practice elsewhere that the current plan
has been in in place for some time it's
appropriate to do that and I think
having taken on responsibility for the
enforcement team now is a good time to
look elsewhere and other examples of
good practice and to look at what our
communities need from enforcement
investigations and reports in order that
we have a plan that can both give those
investigated and communities some
confidence as to the process that the
council will follow in recommendation
3.3 I also we also guys we have take you
on the service transformation work
ETS first say that we
are an ongoing process of transforming
how we work and how we use the software
that we have available we use the same
uniform software enforcement that the
development measurement team have access
to and we have built of experience in
development management about the
effective use of that to manage
caseloads and support officers as they
manage their cases through from
commencement of an investigation through
to a conclusion now the first point to
raise there is that we have recently in
January actually been through an
exercise of data cleansing with old
records from alkylating which are now
translated into uniform that's recently
to working that enables officers to get
a better handle on the playing history
of land and is an important point of
their investigation in order to
understand what may or may not have
happened in the past with any particular
parcel of land so that work was
undertaken from the middle of January
through the end and I think it's fair to
say we were comfortable with the work
that was done by I dogs the software
provider to assist us with that package
and that's now in place we concurrently
have nevertheless a large number of
advocate of investigations to conclude I
think at the moment they stand at about
280 investigations which I think in
fairness has been is now at a level
which is lower than it's probably been
for some considerable time and I've
asked the team to focus on closing the
oldest of cases as an exercise of
reviewing what's in that workload and
what is truly necessary for
investigation
and what the appropriate steps are to
take such an investigation forward
there's various other pieces of
information in the report that go behind
what you have there's reference to the
total number of planning investigations
that were undertaken in 2019 based on a
calendar year and they amount to
somewhat over 500 investigations of
which I've subsequently broken down into
a table the breaches of condition that
have been investigated through 2019 it's
fair to say coming here that committee
wished to understand a little about the
investigation of conditions issue and I
think we've endeavored to do that and to
summarize how that relates to the
Building Control regime there is as I
think it's described at 42 your report a
perception quite widely held that
approved inspectors working the building
control area may be more made very less
less wedded to planning planning
regulation and less in dialogue with
enforcement issues and therefore those
cases as a matter of perception
sometimes the subject of concern I don't
think that's borne out by evidence that
I can put here today chairman in
fairness certainly I've come across
cases which have involved prove
inspectors but equally I come across
cases which have involved Building
Control regulated matters so at the
moment I don't have evidence that
indicates there's a particular problem
around that although I am aware that
there is certainly a perception of that
being the case as regards suffocated
councils conditions they amongst other
stakeholders recommend conditions to us
we as planning our authority have the
responsibility for enforcing those and
we will usually write conditions where
we have taken the suggested language and
text from Suffolk County Council and
made sure its fifth purpose for
investigation ultimately we would in the
course of investigating anything which
is a Suffolk County Council related
condition look to ensure that we're
working in harmony so that were we to
need to serve an enforcement notice the
County Council are in a position to
support us with that formality of action
and obviously the significance of that
comes when one receives an appeal and
one has to defend an appeal against and
the enforcement notice there are a
number of grounds that any person
receiving the enforcement notice main
appeal against those are not described
in your pay
as they are a matter which is
potentially a risk in any particular
enforcement investigation and to that
extent it's something I can talk to
chairman but in terms of our own process
we must work with what planning
Inspectorate have made available to us
and what statute allows and there are a
number of grounds upon which one may
appeal any notice including the fact
that the matter may may not be a breach
of plan control that the time allowed to
remedy that breach may not be long
enough or that the people served with a
notice of not the right people in simple
terms getting to the point of serving
enforcement Otis is a heavy and ownerís
responsibility it is a matter which is
of significant consequence because it
affects the land at all times afterward
the notice comes into effect and to that
extent one as an authority needs to get
that right before serving a notice and
therefore my usual preference is that in
deciding the question of expediency that
the principal act in haste repent at
leisure applies it is appropriate to get
ones investigation correct and have
one's allegations correctly documented
before one launches formal action lest
one be found wanting by either an
inspector or the courts thank you Jim
Thank You members any questions of Phil
or any of the officers on the report and
his presentation cast on the phone Phil
I was really interested in the paper I
think it's brilliant I just as a matter
of interest want to know you said about
enforcement its impact was effectiveness
and reputation is there evidence that
there are other local authorities that
have opted not to undertaken
chairman I'm not aware of any local
authorities that have actually
undertaken not take enforcement I think
my experience over a number of years in
planning is that albeit it is a
discretionary service it is a matter
which is important in communities I
think most authorities wrestle with the
issue that it is to any group to a
degree not a service that brings in
income but is nevertheless very
important locally and I think in terms
of transformation of this service what
we as officers can give you as members
is more information about where we are
in the process I think it's fair to say
we would be unwilling to tell you
everything about the particular point an
investigation might be at because it may
be very sensitive and in fairness where
one has an investigation that may become
a criminal matter
one must be careful with it but there
are certainly quite a lot of information
points along the way which would help
and I think if one takes examples in
both Baberaham amid Suffolk one can
certainly say that community confidence
is bolstered by having an enforcement
team that investigates in an appropriate
way and you can see where investigations
are not undertaken satisfactory they are
the sort of meat and drink of national
newspaper stories another fill of a
total number of investigations into
alleged breaches is high but what you
actually better to do with them is you
know like I said doesn't come up to that
figure so does that mean that most of
them are just alleged and they weren't
on actually founded it's fair to say as
a summary the number of cases that lead
to an enforcement notice being served
and formality are small in comparison to
totality you will usually within a
fairly switch time of your self as it
conclude the lot of cases are either not
a breach or it is not expedient to
enforce the
I don't have the numbers of I look at
hand and part of what I need to do from
here through the rest of the spring is
to sure I can measure just what is
falling out of the system at warp point
because with high medium and low
priorities you know we we don't at the
president have a record in the software
which describes you know what the
proportion of those cases that are close
down for what reason and that's
information I want to be able to capture
and report back
so in essence a lot of places will be
close to relatively quickly what tends
to happen is that the difficult cases
drag and they may drag because you
struggle to find the information you
then need legal advice and then you may
launch onto a more formal process of
investigating and serving their planning
contravention urges to get information
and certainly the most efficient
enforcement teams use a good blend of
action with encouraging cooperation
because it is usually more effective for
the authority and its resources to
encourage somebody to comply with a
notice than to simply serve a notice one
could probably increase the number of
notices fairly rapidly but you might
wanna achieve the same result by
polemics persuasion the carrot and stick
approach if I may put it like that thank
you any other questions so it did you
have a follow-up
council melon Thank You chair um so I
had some experience of both the
enforcement in as a parish councillor
over over several years and actually had
some enforcement action on on myself
there about a decade ago with a visit
and a regularization of something I was
doing and my perception of it as a
parish councillor is that the the
council's been reluctant to take action
and I understand you know what you've
set out in terms of the the steps you
want to take before that happens but
with some individuals is obviously a
kind of persistent pattern of behavior
that builds up that seems to a parish
counselor that it would require some
action which seems to take a long while
to happen is that reluctance or seeming
reluctance to take action because
there's a limit to resources and there's
a cost to going down the legal roof
in very general terms I I think there is
partly a question of experience and
knowledge and experience and
well-qualified enforcement officers are
not a wash in the country so much like
planners there is a bit of a shortage
and you need therefore to use your
resources wisely I think there's that
this is probably more about perception
because you if you if you can't see
what's going on you probably assume
nothing is happening and that's rarely
the case in reality there are sometimes
difficult decisions and sometimes
questions which get to the heart of
whether something is or is not a breach
or whether one particular enforcement
tool or another is the right way of
doing something
everything has risks for instance and to
that extent the nature of the breach
you're looking at usually drives the
complexity from my point of view the
case study about the change of use that
you have is of no surprise to me given
the nature of the breach involved you
know that pattern of time taken and
involvement I imagine that as a parish
counselor watching that will be
extremely disheartening and LU cause you
to lose confidence and I've certainly
seen enough situations where parish
councils you know have a have a a
somewhat black-and-white view of these
things but enforcement investigations
are almost very rarely black-and-white
and this gets back to the point that the
NPP f encourages which is about
proportionate approaches so I think it's
fair to say that there is there's always
a value on have any experienced staff I
think Simon's team are gaining
experience as they go and I think that
with the right use of the software
behind in performance manage cases we
can probably better inform parish
councils and councillors what's going on
which I think has value now in terms of
resources are not convinced at this
stage that I can actually answer
question murmur the other for the simple
reason that I'm in process of looking at
where the workload is and understanding
how the workflow is through from start
to finish for the investigations we have
often and I wouldn't feel comfortable
recommending to you that it is something
that the council spends money on or
although all that it concludes it does
not need to results we have an
additional resource in one officer with
a specific focus on some cases but it's
true to say the most complex cases come
back to the team leader in Simon Bailey
to follow up and then you're on hostage
to the court sometimes for dates
complaining is backed up for dates and I
think there was a considerable lag in
getting appeal dates out of them none of
which speaks to our resources so there
is a question of our effectiveness in
what we do with their resources and
that's something which from my
perspective I haven't included I suspect
we could be more efficient in how we use
the resources and staff that we have and
better use the software to optimize the
way we investigate cases but it will
always come to a point where somebody
needs to have confidence to make a
decision and can sometimes find cases
become stuck when somebody's lacking in
confidence about whether they should
take a course a or course B so if I may
sit on the fence with that resource
question that's possibly where I would
go with it
thank you Tom Burke yes if I can just
perhaps add some some comfort yes I have
never as assistant director said to one
of the officers don't take this action
because it will either be too expensive
or too resource intensive
so that has that has never been a
conversation that we've had so if
there's a perception of that out there
we do need to address that because it
hasn't been something that I've ever
said it as as assistant director thank
you Joe I've got councilor handing him
and then come to the ground in please
thank you just something you said about
building inspectors we're saying there
was more likely to come to you or less
likely
that's something that you think if it
was their in-house service that we could
make you know possibly may not make
money from but like if they would be
able to charge for their services rather
than it being outsourced I Ted take a
view that if you're dealing with
something such as a breach or condition
we as a council have a role in helping
to support delivery and actually there
are some things that we can do and
should try to do which are more
effective about supporting delivery if
somebody hasn't breached a condition we
should try and get them to that point
where they have so it might be an
enforcement investigation but actually
if we pick things up earlier and we're a
little bit more inquisitive which I
think we can do then that bolts on to
the work that Building Control may be
doing is part of their work building
controller always to a degree in tension
because they have to compete with the
market so to some degree they are they
are not our policemen on the ground but
there is a good level of dialogue
between officers they do discuss issues
and options and they are quite effective
at working with builders on the ground
to guide them to the right officer to
talk to how to steer these things I
don't think it's something that you can
charge on I think it's about value added
and I think in terms of that value added
the the important point of the market is
in working with Building Control you're
likely to have a more straightforward
process rather than if you're used in
improving inspector you may well find
that if things do become an
investigation you know you're dealing
with things that you weren't expected to
so I think my perception of that is the
realm of ability control will not alter
what enforcement officers do but between
development management between building
control and enforcement that question of
delivery and helping people get it right
with their conditions it's definitely
something that adds value to what we do
and adds to the role of the counseling
and promoting growth thank you Casa
Grandin thank you chair my questions
regarding retrospective planning
application
I can see that that's a remedy that
becomes the necessary tool but I
wondered if I'm not sure how how it
works so perhaps you could explain
because I can see that for some
developers it might be just a useful way
to kind of get around the system and I
wondered whether the enforcement process
includes a kind of deterrent to
certainly repeat actions of this nature
from the same developer who finds this a
way that he might get the approval
through a backdoor system if you like
and I wonder if there's any sort of
deterrent built-in to the enforcement
process so that a developer even a small
developer doesn't use this as an ongoing
wave of of acting thank you Jim
um the the opportunity does not so much
exist within the enforcement processes
exist within the planning process and
certainly by the District Council and
mid Suffolk District Council have used
the power to decline to determine
retrospective applications where you
might call them perhaps of vexatious is
too strong word but mischievous for sure
and certainly I'm aware of sites where
we have had a line of applications by
somebody looking to prolong a process
effectively where you've had a previous
application which has been determined
and gone to appeal there is an
opportunity under the statutes to
decline to determine a follow-on
application for something of the same
nature or character within
I think it's 12 months doubtless Simon
can correct me with specifics I'm not
sure they're the important point here
today there is a value there to taking a
line with those people who clearly have
a pattern of trying to avoid action by
making applications and from our
perspective when we look at matters that
might be the subject of a retrospective
application which is part and parcel
almost every enforcement investigation
the enforcement officer will speak to
the planning officer about the prospects
for that as an application whether or
not should Thatcher then feed into our
pre application process or whether or
not that would be a lost cause and what
action we should take it nevertheless
remains that an applicant can make an
application based on their own sound
judgment and advice and none of that
necessarily devours us taking
enforcement action
my usual instinct is if one has one
application in process one would not
serve a notice one when he's waiting to
see that determined but if the breach is
so significant and the harm so
significant you would not rule that out
it is very much a question of judgment
in an in a particular case but in most
normal cases one would allow the
application process to play out through
committee if necessary follow an
application for something of the same
character or description I would be
surprised to see if there was a very
clear steer that that wasn't acceptable
if that application came in there would
not necessarily deter me from concluding
enforcement was in very expedient none
of that stops an applicant from making
that sort of application and they might
well then seek to try and argue their
case in front of a planning inspector
but there are mechanisms available to us
they don't necessarily exist we planning
enforcement per se but within the
planning team we do have tools to
discourage mischievous applications
which seek to prevent the evil day if I
may say of the council actually seeking
compliance
and remedying a breach they are not used
frequently but they are available to us
and we do use them Thank You anyone else
oh sorry yes counselor the cruel Thank
You Church mmm
I notice in the report at a variety of
places we have a number of performance
measures usually men measured in days as
to how many days it will take us to do
this that or the other
I just wanted do we measure those
performances and have we got some
results from those that's a work in
progress in fairness council McGraw um
we do measure and can measure the day
that the site visit performers against
the high medium and low priority targets
set within the policy that tells you
nothing about the ongoing investigation
from my perspective the the worth and
the value in reviewing the plan is that
one can then look in detail at for each
of those priorities what one might
reasonably expect they will always be
variations no case is the same and one
will always find a reason why something
may be outside of the usual parameters
but for most investigations I think we
should be able to set those measures at
the moment they don't exist the data in
a clean format has only really existed
since the end of January prior to that
there was a large volume of applications
in the data which meant that running any
kind of management report to describe
measures would have contained a lot of
irrelevant historic data the the you
will now as as you probably obviously
learn from your own inbox is now be
receiving a report on cases and being
opened in cases are being closed I have
a report on cases that are live and open
but I want to get that into a clean form
and to provide meaningful information
with that within that to you before I
share with all members because otherwise
it will simply tell you we have an
enforcement investigation in relation to
this site its life I think from my
perspective if I were a member what I
would want to see is what's happening
with that within the sector and where it
is in the process and those measures
Julie Simon
and my team are looking at and we are
developing them we are presently looking
actively at dealing with the oldest of
cases and from my perspective I've
approached this on the basis of those
cases which are older than 26 weeks and
there are a number of those and looking
to get those to the next to the
substantive action point next in line so
the team are focused on that if you look
on the website you will see that we have
published a note which says that we are
looking at how we transform the service
and to that extent we asked it would be
little manage their own expectations
should we say so I can't
strictly give you much in the way
performance information yet and I just
continue on this point it's not actually
it's an observation because this is
largely not my own personal experience
this is what has been reported to me by
a member and members of the public and
it's also a perception I believe that it
is it is historical as I say my recent
experience has been merely and reporting
a possible concern about something
that's been immediately taken on as an
active case of hoping sent an email see
your active case such as I I didn't even
know I had an active case so in that
instance as over performance there is a
definitive and definite or an
improvement I think and I hope to see
that continue but I think this report is
a very good step in that direction I'm
gonna come back to that in
recommendations
Kousaka and oh sorry Tom Barker's got
something but I just wanted to through
your chair I just wanted to add to what
Phil was describing there just in terms
of the number of days and what is
reasonable and how should we do things
that the application process contains a
number of those things within
regulations so an application will be
received you will do 21 days
consultation with people you will
process a minor application within eight
weeks you will process a major
application within 13 weeks or 16 weeks
and the government has its planning
guarantee that if we take more than 26
weeks then we should be refunding of
so there is a there are some parameters
within the planning application process
that don't exist within the enforcement
process and one of the things that Phil
Simon Dooley and the team are looking at
is actually do those timescales that the
application process gives us provides
something that we could look to mirror
in terms of enforcement so what is it
that we should or could be looking to do
within eight weeks what is it that we
should be looking to do within 13 or 16
weeks and I think that's why Phil
referred earlier to 26 weeks
well why 26 weeks and not 25 weeks or 30
weeks or 35 weeks it borrowing from some
of the time periods that exist within
the planning system as it currently
exists just seems reasonable and so so
that is starting to inform how we look
at complexity and and the various
different stages within the process and
that's something that your plan in due
course when the task and finish quick
look at it can seek to put those kind of
expectations in if I can add to that I
think that I'm adding to what I said and
I don't know I didn't go myself but
colleagues as part of the development
review of our workload visited Milton
Keynes a few minutes ago and we're
fortunate enough to get a bit of a
briefing on how their enforcement plan
works and I don't know Julie is it worth
on you adding anything to what we saw
there and where that might take us with
a review
so yeah we went to Newton case based on
their working the planning side of
things but part of that has it included
some information about enforcement they
originally had about a thousand cases
which they reduce to about two or three
hundred over a period of time they have
a scoring chart for assessment of harm
so they basically score every report as
it comes in in this to whether there is
farm or not we have sort of looked at
that as an option but it's basically
rating every every report for for
instance is there any Highway Safety is
there any what is the age of the breach
so has it been going on for a long time
has somebody oh you just noticed is it
is it worth investigation is it worth
taking up and asking whether they need
to put an application in will that
application be supported or is are we
just asking that's what an application
in in event eventually will be refused
so actually are we wasting time dragging
the process out is is it something that
affects other people or is it something
that just affects the person living on
the site is there their neighbors around
it so this there is there is options on
where we go next and Milton Keynes had
been quite proactive at reducing the
caseload and coming back to people and
keeping people informed there is there
is also other options of providing
enforcement information online which we
are looking at as well obviously because
of the confidentiality of the
complainant it's how we keep people
informed but but obviously on about on
balance is is we don't want to give too
much away it has in respective lose
actually like the complaint in the first
place so trying to keep that neutral
thank you um can we go again yes okay
didn't have to say again in quite that
tone of voice Jerry though quite
understandable I do appreciate it I just
thought it would be useful and I wanted
to look at the case studies a little bit
if that was possible and that's what
they've been supplied for after all
and did the last one first if I may
because for the life of me um I wasn't
entirely certain as to what the breach
of condition in the first case had been
and and the before and after photographs
left me none the wiser it was fairly
obvious with the hedge I could see that
one but I couldn't quite see I mean
please put a Blue Ranger over here I
don't know if that was the breach but I
just wonder if you could describe what
the nature of that case was Thank You
councilman it was to do with landscaping
so in front of the vehicle in the
photograph you can see a number of
spirals plastic spirals which would
contain the hedge planting that was
required by the Planning Commission as a
planning condition that's super thanks
very much just wasn't certain second one
was whether the lengthy case the five
and a half year one referred to earlier
by by Phil there and that's that looks a
very contentious matter I mean that goes
through eight appeals and involves
contempt hearings on two occasions now
guessing that's a cap on the caravan
site or a a mobile home site that was
being used improperly now those are not
uncommon in Baberaham its suffered we
all have heard of cases in both areas I
just wondered if you could give us some
pointers on that type of issue it's a
very contentious one and I think it is
something that we can expect to see
again that particular case started out
as over report
offense and grew into unauthorized use
of land for stationing of caravans that
used for residential purposes as it
turned out that the people that were
using it were gypsy and traveler
heritage but they were looking to settle
on that piece of land they'd bought it
they want to they wanted to use it for
living on but the principle issue that
we'd had has a problem with that was a
highway safety issue in relation to the
access because of the lands proximity to
various highway issues humpback bridge
and fairly significant bend in the road
so well after whilst they applied those
those applications of refusal we refused
they made eight applications in the end
for various different things some of
those applications came after we serve
the enforcement notice so we decline
determine those and after serving after
non-compliance with the enforcement
notice and subsequent prosecution and
further non-compliance we then went down
the roof obtaining an injunction in
injunction which they didn't comply with
so we took the vertical a further two
times in on contempt and that and that
ultimately resulted with a threat of
prison time to them leaving the site so
quite a particular set of circumstances
yeah and probably not typical of the
sort of cases that would normally come
to or towards some planning enforcement
one would hope I wouldn't describe them
as typical no that one that one's
unusual it's not they're rare but they
do happen we have we have a number of
cases ongoing where the person that is
responsible for the breach persists
despite our best efforts to advise them
otherwise those probably five or six
that are
of a length which is you know largely
unacceptable and similar in in this case
five plus years to try and get something
resolved and using all the options
available to us in order to achieve
desired outcome
can I follow on it while I'm doing this
some cases and general approach because
one of the biggest concerns in planning
enforcement for members I think and for
residents across the two districts is we
have a lot of large planning
applications with multiple planning
conditions applied to them and any
planning enforcement regime needs to
needs to carry the confidence of the
public that planning conditions will be
enforced and also but also the time
scale over which these processes take
place now I know from my own observation
that is that there's a lot of often a
lot of time spent just persuading people
but I wonder if if the officers could
describe the approach they take with
many of the larger applications that we
both face where we're talking about I
don't know 20 30 or 40 even might be
forties a bit much different planning
conditions that may be subject to you
know sort of slightly different sorts of
interpretation by the developer as
opposed to ourselves
absolute vague but I'm just wondering
the general approach if I lead and Simon
can correct me when I go wrong and the
first and foremost point is we for the
largest sites we try and make sure we've
got an effective relationship with the
Builder so that we have a line of
communication with them usually with the
larger sites they are not isolated cases
and there's normally a sense of a
dialogue about those breaches when
they're brought to our attention or we
become aware of them from other reasons
and you know typically one then
encounters so internal communication
problems sometimes in some of those
businesses which mean that those on site
aren't necessarily reading the same
piece of paper that they should be you
know the first and foremost approach is
obviously to try and
carriage compliance within a reasonable
period of time and it depends on what
that condition is if somebody is started
groundworks and you've got an
archeological condition to discharge
well that's something for you no
immediate action because otherwise you
will damage the remains that are in
situation
a series of trees as I'm aware of a
relatively recent investigation is
evolving and then you have a
conversation about the discharge of that
condition if there is a condition
involved and where the planning team are
with their approach to that good or bad
on planning merit so there's there's
quite close conversation between those
two teams to work out and what action is
the important point next you know it's
very hard to to generalize about this I
think it is important that we understand
and take a more effective view around
how we deal with conditions and that's
not just about enforcing them but
actually helping people to discharge
them they are you know quite onerous
even for small developments to navigate
successfully and a failure to do that
properly can if you play a worst case
scenario has led to some large companies
being exposed to a high sill bill
because they've failed to discharge
their conditions of the right timing so
these are not matters that are light and
are quite significant for the building
industry and I think they're only slowly
waking up to that risk not quite sure
what comfort I could put around that
other than saying I think it's certainly
on our radar as an important thing to
get right across the team one typically
finds that the pressure of construction
management is a problem that the white
van man turning up too early the
delivery lorry parking outside a site
etc some of those things then become a
problem because they are they
within the highway saying therefore we
wouldn't normally have scope to enforce
them and we will try and encourage good
behavior where we can but we try and use
what tools are available and to a degree
that is that's the cost-effective
approach rather than to approach matters
without an enforcement notice as a
general point around enforcement
investigations of all nature's Simon
Julie and I have discussed the
opportunity to use more planning
contravention notices as a tool to
encourage behavior now planning
contravention notice is effectively a
formal question asked of somebody which
requires a response I believe within 21
days or is actually an offense not to
respond and my experience has been that
they are a way of getting someone's
undivided attention you don't always get
the answer you're expecting you don't
always get the answer that you want
because sometimes people need a second
or third notice served upon them and
certainly in in my time I've come across
people who really didn't like being
asked questions because they felt they
didn't want to answer them but they are
a way of ensuring people are focused
that they have a problem to solve and I
think when it comes to breach or
condition issues if we use our an
administration team more effectively we
can probably give the officers some
background support and indeed do that
around wasteland notices and other
matters I think there are opportunities
there for our support team to be more
effectively engaged in supporting their
officers to do some of the work that
ease puts the officers in a good
position with information and along the
way also encourages the right behaviors
councillor Kirsten sorry can someone
like to just add to that
sorry apologies just to finish off at
the point you were making and that said
the comments
none of those cases that we've got that
have gone on for lots of years involves
large-scale developments or large-scale
developers they will they will all be
individuals and as some of that is that
they just don't want to engage with the
process and some of that is they just
don't understand the process we do get
reports of breaches of condition by
large-scale developers they relatively
quick and straightforward to resolve
because those developers have got a
reputation to uphold
they've got shareholders they've got
goodwill that they need to maintain yeah
its most of those would have come about
because they've either forgotten to
discharge that condition or it's in the
process of them doing something so you
know we can might get a report that the
condition is being breached because
there's activity on site and what
they're actually doing is trying to
discharge the condition the archaeology
for example or something like that so
we'll go and do a site visit establish
that to be the case and then report back
on that and most of the time that would
be a case closed because there is no
breach hence the Kasten
right
thinking um so at the end of last week
in Brantford the Bison site we had a
some emergency enforcement building was
dangerous and we had the storm come in
and it's everything seemed to happen
very quickly that the building was taken
down and that the danger to the public
that that building presented was dealt
with very quickly then that was great
and I was really pleased about that but
what I'm with our priority list of high
low and medium where does that site sit
in there with the where there's no
activity so much going on this site
there's no unauthorized building or
anything but we with it does pose
potentially a danger to the public
I just yeah we're with that where would
that be in our priority list please
[Music]
guide you that's medium is it that's a
medium case I mean you know obviously as
what was you know one of the biggest was
the biggest listed building in in
Suffolk it might well have been a high
priority case but much of that interest
having been burnt that alters the
perspective on it I think in part the
answer this question is that a high
medium and low approach to a policies is
too simplistic and it doesn't actually
helpfully give everybody confidence
about what steps happen next so that
case of itself I believe the action
involved was was a building and drove
dangerous structure action not planning
enforcement and obviously they know
that's a that's a life and
life and limb exercise think from our
point of view the the site itself if
it's stable it is in a medium priority
case rather than the high priority case
but that does not actually tell anybody
anything about how how our involvement
with that side because it is
multidisciplinary how our involvement
goes forward from here and I think a
review of the policy a review of the
plan would allow us to describe it
somewhat perhaps in the way that Julie
was describing in relation to milton
keynes approach which is to look beyond
simple priority into complexity and harm
because as as simon was saying in
relation to breach of condition cases
there is a question of what's what's
urgent and what's complex and a breacher
condition cases can sometimes be
straight for what they can sometimes be
complicated and if you know as a member
of the public that something is being
treated as a complex issue gives you
more understanding that it may not
happen overnight and that there will be
no time time necessary to get that
investigation right thank you I've got a
couple of queries you've spoken about
degree of harm you've spoken about
urgency and there's also coming into
play the possibility of reinstatement so
if I can look at two scenarios one is a
mature line of trees which have a TPO on
them somebody's come along with the
chainsaw and started to cut them down
the degree we look at the degree of harm
the urgency and the possibility of
reinstatement I'm not sure where that
would be on the list of priorities but
there's also looking again now at the
building being constructed on per piece
of land where there's no planning no
planning application whatsoever that
could be a degree of harm there but
there's always the possibility of
reinstatement because you can knock it
down and plow it up and plant grass or
whatever in either of those cases do you
have the power to stop what's going on
thank you and yes the TPO
cases that would we've registered with
us as a high priority and we aim to get
somebody out the same day or the next
day
unauthorized works - a TP or a criminal
offense strict liability offense so once
we could caution the people on site if
we see somebody on site and advise them
that they're committing an offense and
the need to stop and we could then
proceed with we could take this court
straight away as soon as possible we
could speak spigot about getting them
into court as soon as possible that
might not necessarily stop them from
cutting down the trees but we could then
require them to reinstate the trees with
something of a similar size or species I
think is what a legislation says service
you know the line of ten mature Oaks
they would be expected to replace them
with a line of ten mature Oaks whether
or not the course would actually be able
to achieve that I don't I'm not sure
because we've never had that experience
but that's what the legislation says in
relation to a building you weren't
talking about conversion of the building
there we've got a paddock somebody's
decided to start constructing a large
building on it
the locals all know that yeah there's
going to be a big building on there
because that's what the owner of the
paddock has said but there they haven't
put in any planning application there's
no indication that they wish to do so we
would need to look at that in terms of
the harm and it's whether or not it
would be acceptable in planning terms if
it was then we could invite an
application for its retention in order
to regularize it if it was considered by
offices enforcement and planning offices
to not be something we could support via
the local plan then we could tell them
to stop and we could serve them with a
temporary stop notice we should require
them to stop for 28 days
after that 28 days we would then need to
serve them with notice if we wanted them
to not continue
and I'm now thinking about a a building
the person or the individual who's
responsible for the alleged Bree if they
if they were determined to carry on is
there ever a possibility that you might
say well the only way to resolve this is
although it's unlikely they would get
planning permission that they that they
would they should put in for a put in an
application just to clear the air would
you would you ever suggest that to the
person who's building I don't think we
would ever encourage Germans somebody to
make an application which was unlikely
on balance to succeed you know clearly
with the work with the worst of it in
breaches of enforcement people often
take their own advice and will
nevertheless do that and and will work
on the basis if they can binds up
nothing they'll buy themselves time by
it you know we have various tools in the
toolbox and ultimately we could seek
injunctions in relation to some of these
matters we can serve an enforcement
notice with immediate effect but there
are consequences and penalties if we
take away people's and/or usual rights
to appeal so the the the the likelihood
of us inviting an application was would
not be successful seems it's certainly
not something I would encourage the team
to do I am aware in the past some
enforcement officers in formal
authorities have managed their caseloads
down by encouraging applications which
then creates problem with planning team
but in a broad terms we work together
much more effectively and I think that
is unlikely to happen as a as a
principle but it wouldn't stop somebody
from making an application to buy time
and all see whether they could win on
appeal thank you
the castle the cool thank you Jay just
to follow on from that so as I
understand it and this is the point I
wanted to come to earlier actually this
is a non-criminal platter but
so basically we're dealing with civil
war civil law here so the war possibly
civil law here and that the only people
who can apply as any civil actors is the
planning enforcement team it's not
something that anybody else can
undertake but there are and I want to
stress this point that there are
penalties there are financial penalties
as well as reputational penalties and
that's a very important point I think
this meeting should bring out in that
although it's not criminal and I'm a
must admit I think we've all seen that
various times perhaps in various parts
of social media with the word that's
criminal used it's not much good saying
no I'm afraid it isn't criminal but that
is the case but it does imply penalties
now the question as to what those
penalties should be and whether they're
sufficient as another matter but I think
we've had some examples so I just wanted
to draw that out thank you but I think I
think some said that working on cutting
down trees with the TPO is a criminal
offense yeah yeah there are some so
there's some exemptions yes certainly I
mean if you look at the the items if you
if you wait to the policy you'll see the
items are high-priority include works to
trade works to listed buildings which
are a criminal offense but generally
speaking breaching planning or is not
and I think you know there is a there is
a general expectation in the public's
mind but it should be and it isn't and
perhaps with good reason and the the
plan and the policy is therefore from my
perspective an important way of managing
expectations so that everyone is
comfortable that it is being done in a
proportionate way and that my experience
with this is ultimately that people do
get there come up and
ultimately and that and what then
becomes unsatisfactory for a period of
time is a unavoidable consequence just
to adverse share the report does make
the point that we are not in the
business of penalizing yeah we are not
trying to apply penalties that would be
a petty way to act and the report makes
that quite clear
castle never sorry
councillor Osborne sorry Thank You mr.
chair first of all I'd like to thank the
plenty name and Simon bailiff reinforce
not I think this is a very very good
paper and in terms of the joint look the
joint enforcement I think is excellent
and I was just wondering whether
actually are bigger councils parish or
town would benefit from having a copy of
this is to to ensure that they know
exactly what's going on just one
question mr. chair and that is the three
site visits under 23 site visits
undertaken 27 site visits that you know
that is excellent and can I just ask how
did you how did these site visits come
about was it because of the application
or was it because of residents or
councillors actually coming forward with
a situation where you've you've gone out
to visit I would just like to say my
experience I've had nothing but
excellent of responses from from the
enforcement team and I can't for
anything know done but I just like to
know that in fact you know is it
is it because you get in a lot of
residents or is it coming from the
application itself so in the bundle
you've got a draft workload report which
lists out 27 site because it's
undertaken that's a snapshot of workload
in a week so from my perspective and
this is a work in progress
members information that tells you that
something is happening in relation to
those cases it doesn't tell you more
than that and I think that that's simply
in line with the policy that is us
visiting those sites and we will have
aimed to do that in accordance with the
policy for each and every one but it's a
piece of information it then confirms
that that action has happened so it's it
is a snapshot for our workload purposes
it is I think useful to you to see that
you know sometimes not obviously a
parent Ward officers are doing with
their time and to know that have
confidence that something is happening
with one investigation or another you
know I think that I think that's very
helpful miss chairman that and I only
hope that we get the sonic visits
because of perception from from the
public is that there are things going on
which they're not agreeing with and
perhaps they are committed in a year and
if breach early enforcement thank you
thank you I think we've got councillor
Mellon and then councilman McClaren
Thank You chair yeah can echo that last
comment that I think if it's not already
a public document that that some the the
it should be it'll be very useful to
have that out there for parish councils
to look at my question was is is
enforcement purely reactive I mean
officer we have you know hundreds
perhaps thousands of development sites
and lots and lots of conditions on some
of them easier only reacting to
complaints or is there any kind of
proactive nature to it the simple answer
is it is it is generally speaking
reactive and we don't have the results
or expect to take a sort of proactive
approach where others might provide that
information for instance so
with dialogue between the planning team
and the enforcement team if there are
things that might become an issue we all
keep you know colleagues will keep their
their fellow officers informed about
issues that might be emerging and I'm
not I'm not expecting that we take a
more proactive approach to enforcement
matters because that could become one
would have to choose in which cases you
would do that and under what
circumstances to give the public
confidence and that could become quite
quite something to write into a locally
enforcement plan and arguably quite a
resource drain if if that was abortive
work Thank You Cara McClaren I know it's
early days in your development of your
systems and team when that is sort of
established do you see implementing some
regular audit systems on how the
department is functioning and achieving
its objectives I I think it's fair to
say that's an appropriate activity to do
once we've got to a position where we
comfortable we've got the process in
place in the way we want it and that
we've got the right resource doing the
work that we need to have done so I'm I
see no reason why we wouldn't audit and
review that in due course my only
instinct is that the work in progress is
being described here I'm not expecting
and I always make reference to spring
watch being in May I'm not expecting to
got to a point where I can really know
best around resources and that process
and until we got to the middle of the
year and that then would lead us to look
at how we're performing you know at the
year-end I would suggest there's a
package of software use we use called
uniform I think I described the
performance management software that we
would expect to develop in in parallel
with that that's called enterprise and
that it's a very effective reporting
tool used in our development service
which allows us to see how the
he's flying through the process and see
bottlenecks or issues quite early on so
I would hope that we'd get ahead in
terms of the audit circumstance but I
welcome that as an opportunity to
confirm that things are running in a
smooth way but it's from my point of
view I work in progress at this point in
time thank you Oh cancel another I too
would like to say what an excellent
document the actual joint local planning
enforcement plan is and as vice-chair of
the stone market town council planning
committee I wonder where that were
useful we could perhaps have copies of
this document or even perhaps a short
training session arranged for the I
don't know with my colleague came to
scarf who was on that committee would
agree with me we've got quite a few new
members on that committee who obviously
don't sit on planning a district or not
district councillors and I think this
this could be a short session on this
could be very beneficial to them and all
of us generally actually if that could
be arranged
just look cool on that very point chair
I'd like to add when I was referring to
this earlier that we should add an extra
recommendation we might be early for
that but this has seems an appropriate
point to add it because I think it's not
just useful for parishes and towns I
honestly believe this is the best
collection of this information and I'm
sure it was available before but I
didn't know where to look I do now and
this reports been really useful I think
this will be used to every member so I
would add recommendation 3.4 that we
should make members aware of this report
and provide a link to it on our website
regardless of the fact that it may be
superseded by a later document that
would help inform for those people who
might be serving on the working group in
3.2 so I think 3.4 is a valid suggestion
perhaps inaudible Thank You mr. chairman
yeah absolutely agree with counsel
McCraw on this one and I just like to
say that it has answered a lot of
questions that I could have asked today
thank you thank you Phil you wanted to
have a few words and chairman if I may
by good fortune you and I will be
meeting sometime after this one to
discuss the very matter of nourishing
campus and Town Council training which I
think is an opportunity we can pick up
from that conversation from my
perspective we as officers have started
a conversation with some Association
local councils about Parrish training
that's not concluded yet and we may
choose to do something different around
this I certainly think that planning
training is part of this and enforcement
is a matter that it will be useful to
train on I think with a 200 or so
parishes to do that one was measure
one's cloth and I want enforcement
officers investigating cases so we would
need to structure and plan that but I
see no reason why we wouldn't explore
that as a path of planning training and
the only point I'd make is that the
current plan I foresee will need to
change into a new plan and I'd rather
manage my expectations around training
on that because the plan is benchmark of
what to expect in standard terms but
there's certainly a lot of information
about how the process works which I
think parish you should be aware of and
made aware of and if they know there's a
plan and that the plan is going to
change then they can at least look at it
and be feted as we go thank you
are we ready to move on to debate and
consider recommendations we've got three
recommendations obviously the contents
of the report will be noted the second
is to recommend to cabinet the
establishment of a member officer
task and finish working group I think is
recommended to review the plan and that
this group we requested to have regard
to best practice and other examples of
other published local enforcement plans
in that process of review we've got
three point three which is an update on
progress with service transformation
work within the planning enforcement
service to be provided back to this
committee and three point four was to
make members
did you have a prasada wordings make
members aware of the report and provide
a link to it on our website just as a
purely as a piece of information and an
understanding because I mean effectively
we are the ones who are going to be
answering into our in our communities
when people generally raise these these
objections and these concerns and as
Simon has pointed out yes sometimes
there is nothing to them it's just a
matter of understanding and
interpretation often the understanding
is that such work doesn't have to take
place immediately and it can take place
at any point in a lengthy timeframe but
members having this this level of
understanding I think would help members
in doing that part of the job we're
moving towards recommendations but I
think Emily would like to have a few
words before we make any mistakes in our
recommendation thank you chairman and
yeah just to clarify that 3.2 you would
actually have to be a recommendation to
council with planning being a council
function rather than an executive
function and so the working group it
follows then should be formal from the
whole council rather than just
restricted to the cabinet
thank you Emily um with with that are
you happy to propose oh sorry I'm just
one thing the three point three does not
include a time frame and I'm very happy
that it's open-ended but would it be
useful to consider a six month time
frame and therefore look to August as a
point in time where I come back to you
and report on progress
well that would be a good starting point
if we aim towards August and if it
doesn't it does fit even better in
September or whatever so with with all
of those yeah and and three and
three-quarter or three point four excuse
me right sorry we can either have a task
and finish group or a working group a
task and finish group do not need any
improvement from Council or cabinet
whereas working group would need to go
to council to be agreed
that's where we've been doing in other
areas we're doing working groups across
various policy initiatives it was it was
originally framed as a member working
group it was reframed as a task and
finish group on the basis that this is
about the the reworking of the
enforcement plan which is a start and
finish activity and that was why it was
that was why we were describing a task
and finish group because comes together
meet a few times gets the plan in place
and finishes so do we remove the word
Council chair because that doesn't
report to council decision I think you
said Henrietta it doesn't report to
Council task and finish it up can report
to Council but it doesn't need to be
agreed to be established by the council
so we can recommend the establishment of
are you happy with that yeah so three
point two is to recommend the
establishment of a member officer task
and finish group without the word
working to review and so on and three
point three we've added on to the end
provided back to committee in August
2020 in six months Kaster scarf we carry
a little uncertain about the task of
finish group would it be then a task and
finish group of this committee or would
it be a task unfinished group of the
council so how would how would we make
or how would they make appointment
if I can give a couple of options to the
committee
you could have an overview of scrutiny
Tasker finish group which would be
members from this committee and then you
could choose to go up other people on
say for example the chairs of the
planning committee might be a sensible
option or you could just recommend that
the council as a whole creates a task or
finish group and remember this is member
and officer so actually officers would
just go away and through group leaders
ask for volunteers to come on to the
group so you've got two options really
as to how much control the committee
wants to retain over that task and
finish group are you happy with option B
option B so we don't need to control
this so no so the word the wording as it
now stands in three point two is okay
yeah so we've got a proposal do we have
a seconder
councillor Muller and are we all in
favor please yes we are all in favor
thank you very much big thank you to the
officers we've had I think a really good
to and fro on questions and answers I
think it's been a really helpful it's
been very informative for me and I'm
sure for all members of the the
committee thank you very much indeed
[Applause]
okay thank you very much we we move on
to item nine which would be an
information bulletin if we have one but
there are there are no information
bulletins this month item 10 is the
forthcoming decisions list members have
had an opportunity to look through this
I couldn't see anything there that would
require us to carry out any scrutiny so
are you happy that we move then on to
item 11 which is the Baber overviewed
scrutiny work plan council macaw are you
happy with it anything you yes Joan
happy with it I think we're pretty much
ready for the rest of this year allowing
for small changes that might take place
we can deal with those in the chairs
meeting as if that a few and the Vice
Chair sir our happy was that idea Adrian
yes you're happy with that basis we can
deal with that I think there's enough on
our work plan that doesn't mean we're
overloaded and nothing generally
speaking the midst of an overview and
scrutiny work plan it mirrors the Bible
there's one or two items which is
specific to babe others are just
specific to mid Suffolk so are we happy
to - no we carry on with the work both
work plans as they as they presently
stand Thank You council McCraw what one
item that I believe we were discussing
regarding some development of future
work plans
I believe the monitoring officer had
some suggestions in that direction and I
was wondering if that might be well
would work wells being folded in with
the review of overview and scrutiny that
both of us about the joint committee
will be undertaking in May that would
seem to be a sort of natural synergy
that if we review previous year and look
forward to the next year at the same
time we'll be doing that anyway with
that would that fit with your plans and
the
any issue around that is that the
overview and scrutiny committee submits
their work plans to annual council I
believe for approval so you might need
to do it before then I do think there's
anything constitutionally that
necessarily requires it to go to annual
council but it's just our customer
practice well okay so we'll follow the
round unusual custom and practice and
we'll have it ready by then I'm sure we
can manage that in chairs and we can add
it to the agenda for general discussion
it's related to allister's allister's
work plans here the Bellevue house on
the 18th of May yes are we sure that we
all have sufficient arrangements there
for Bellevue house because it's still
undergoing its crew applications of the
of the house from what I understand in
informal discussions with Emily attack
if it isn't ready we may have to delay
that but we can put it into the work
program at the appropriate time as no
point in doing it it's already been held
back but I think councillor Grandin may
have some more knowledge on that I was
hoping you did have some more knowledge
on that sorry Kel sugandha um I noticed
that on the mid Suffolk scrutiny
committee there's something that I I
think in this I've missed it should be a
joint which is reviewing civil parking
enforcement and I haven't noticed it on
as a joint metal have I missed it we
decided that we'd already reviewed the
joint working plan and that was the
Baber
that myself and adrienne we didn't feel
that we needed to do so as we think we'd
already done it and since the items just
been withdrawn from cabinet because
certain decisions haven't been made
elsewhere that affect our own adoption
planning enforcement I regard to
something of a moot point I did notice
it myself but I honestly there was no
appetite but from the vapor of members
were as represented by a dream than
myself to do so now do you tell me that
the babe remembers do have such an
appetite I'm happy to continue put it
back on but at the moment I'm not sure I
see a point but we did we did examine
the joint parking plan and the tools kit
toolkit available now until civil
parking enforcement is actually in place
what is it we're scrutinizing I mean
it's been held up again because I
believe that Suffolk County Council have
not provided full information for our
cabinet to be able to make a decision
and without that information they can't
make a decision and then my point of
view I don't see that we have anything
to scrutinize until the decision has
been made I think possibly the
difference was that at Council mid
suffer there were a lot more queries and
unknowns and debate on the introduction
of civil parking enforcement than
possibly there were the baby council
meeting so it was it was as a reaction
to that really that he was put into the
mid suffered work plan but because we
had we had looked at the overall parking
plan previously not that not the plan
for civil enforcement but the parking
plan I think Baber probably felt that
there was enough in that parking plan
which had been agreed to cover the
eventualities of civil enforcement on
the other hand mid Suffolk councils did
not think the same then that's why
that's why it's in the midst of a plan I
mean it would be quite easy if if things
change in the next month or so to put to
put it in as a joint item rather than as
mid Suffolk only item but I think
that didn't seem to be the same need
from Babers there wasn't been suffered
if I could grow yeah if I could clarify
the Baber a position as I see it is that
we have a toolkit but as yet we have yet
yet to decide which bits the toolkit we
would use in which places so I don't see
that we can really sort of already
scrutinized the toolkit and we've
accepted that the toolkit is a fit and
proper document with a variety of
different methods that could be used in
different areas but without decisions
being made we have nothing to scrutinize
until that decision is made if it's
being is it still being implemented on
the 6th of April your guess is as good
as mine because do to come to cabinet
this month and it was with gold at the
last minute from cabinet so I would have
to take advice from officers and from
the cabinet as to where they see it now
but the cabinet didn't feel that they
had the information on which to make any
decisions so they weren't going to make
any decisions is that a fair reading of
the situation yeah so the situation is
that mid suffered cabinet have adopted
the joint parking plan and they the
cabinet haven't so that means to go back
to bay the cabinet to be revisited but
the fact of the matter is that civil
parking enforcement is going to come in
and has got to be implemented in some
way yeah exactly well it's nationwide so
that that's got to be implemented in
some way by the given time we just don't
know what the details of it are and what
policies will be used where so if it's
going to be implemented as it sounds
like it will have to be should we not
once it's been enforced for about three
months be looking at how it so should we
not put it into our plan for maybe June
June July committee I don't think three
months is going to give you significant
amounts of data
I would suggest six months might be
better as an as a map as a minimum and
it could be even be but before you
actually get any useful that's been a
principle we've had adopted in the past
is that we don't try and measure on a
very small sample we try to use as large
a sample as we possibly can preferably a
year because yeah but I would accept six
months and in fact since our current
work plan has got enough on it six
months would be more appropriate but I
mean that six months could be seventeen
it could be eight it could be something
like that but you do need to have the
data and bear in mind you will have a
delay in collecting that data so to get
six months worth of data will probably
take eight months or nine months if you
follow me my concern would be that if
there are any
worries about its implementation in
practice that things get ironed out
quite quickly rather than because of
processes being a slave thing that
rather you know that we we nip things in
the bud if you like with rather than
allow things to take hold too quickly we
were able to report back any issues I
think rather than link there are some
problems with that in a sense because we
are talking about two separate other
authorities actually carrying out our
parking provision in labor but very soon
Edmonds and West Suffolk will supply for
the west of the district and Ipswich
will supply for the east of the district
and without a steer from cabinet I mean
I think this it's just a bit nebulous
at the moment to make decisions we can
keep it in mind with the principle but I
don't think we can make a decision
without an information base on which to
make that decision so ideally I would
leave it at the moment and that's but
then it doesn't mean we can't come back
to it at any time I mean we can probably
get something on an agenda with about a
month or twos notice
wouldn't that be fair to say Henry oh
absolutely yeah if I sorry yeah honestly
if I could just say this the there were
a number of issues at Council that that
had not been resolved prior to the
implementation and this the purpose of
the scrutiny on the 23rd of March is to
have a an information bulletin updating
on the points that were still uncertain
when it was debated at Council it's not
a review of how well it's working it's
is everything set up ready for a start
in April and do we know what it's going
to cost how it's going to be done and so
on because there were a number of things
which were not understood but I think
Emily would like word and then we'll
come to Dave more if it's useful to the
committee I actually think this would be
a very interesting topic for the
committee to take forward a post
implementation review that kind of
scrutiny is actually one of the key
functions of the overview and scrutiny
committee so I think it has merits in
taking it forward I think probably as
councillor McCrory's alluded to actually
just leaving it as a and item in the
bottom part of your work plan to begin
with rather than scheduling it for an
exact date might be sensible so you can
see how the picture starts to emerge and
but what I would say is that you need to
be very clear about what your measure of
success would be so if you're going to
look at how successfully the plan has
been implemented you need to be very
clear on on what kind of measures and
therefore what data you want and
actually agreeing some of that perhaps
in chairs briefing would be useful so
offices can start to collect it from the
outside
I think I think yeah I think that's very
that's very good advice so perhaps we
ought to do a bit of scoping at the next
chairs in vice chairs meeting so that we
can set the parameters as as Emily said
so are you all happy with that so it
doesn't mean a change
yeah because you the whole process will
be it will be a lengthy one so I would
like to you know for what we do to be
useful and to be seen to be nipping
things in the bud early rather than
waiting a year down the line I'd have to
say that on that subject I'd expect
Sudbury and happily members in
particular to take an interest in this
matter I'm sure that would be the case
and stone market members and I think
members in rural areas as well who
wanted to get something out of this
councillor mother yeah Thank You chair
I'm very keen for certainly the mid
Suffolk Oh huge scrutiny committee to
include this on our March programme
because even yesterday I've had
questions from Cedars Park resinous
Association exactly what's gonna happen
with parking enforcement so I would
actually benefit I think from having to
be able to speak and look what can you
do what can't you do so that I can then
report back to them first I'm sorry but
yes it is a seeking of information
rather than the debate that we're
looking for in March and by all means
come along yeah right can we now can we
now move on we know to the point where
we need to discuss absolutely with
public
[Applause]
yeah so before everybody needs to be
here for the decision on whether or not
to exclude the public you can't go yet
labor members we've we needed to to
consider whether pursuant to part one a
schedule 12 a of the Local Government
Act 1972 the public be excluded from the
meeting for the business specified below
on the grounds that if the public were
present during this item it's likely
there would be the disclosure to them
have exempt information as indicated
against the item so can I have a
proposer the point of order is chair is
that appropriate for the babe remembers
to be voting on this we have no
knowledge and no interest directly in it
as this is a joint committee we're going
to have to exclude you and we all gonna
have to do that jointly so that the vape
amid some members can vote on the mid
Suffolk minutes if you see what I mean
I just think it's a bit weird that we're
going to be voting to exclude ourselves
as henriette's described because it's a
joint committee you do have that option
because of course you could vote not to
exclude yourself so we abstain would
that be a sensible solution well it is a
joint it is a joint Meteor up to and
including this point and council McCraw
as you might recall and we've had
previously had issues with minutes that
has been taken from a separate or a
singular committee lasting six months
before they came back to a singular
committee and members were complaining
about that they couldn't remember got it
going on so they couldn't actually
remember what was supposed to be in the
minutes and therefore it was decided I
think sometime last year that we should
take the individual minutes to the joint
meetings as soon as possible so that
they could be signed off by the
appropriate
meeting counsel counselor Osbourne Thank
You mr. chairman as much as I enjoy
being with the mix-up of proof on the
joint
I've got no no problems but I would like
to just vote proposed that we actually
leave the Weber members do leave the
meeting so they and it's you guys can
guess all yourselves out thank you do it
the do you have a second I'd second that
motion
thank you and is everyone in favor
everyone is in favor thank you very much
you